I've loved virtually everything Martin
Scorsese has done especially this yep he
directed the bad video what's your name
boy Hugo Hugo was directed by Martin
Scorsese it's about a little boy who
lives in a train station up where the
big clock tower is and he secretly is up
there wining the clocks and fixing them
when need be no one knows he's there and
he likes to look down the people the
various shops that are there he sees
Sacha Baron Cohen who is the guard who
is traversing this area with this
Doberman of his he sees Ben Kingsley who
owns a shop of his own and his little
granddaughter Chloe grace Moretz or Hit
Girl or the crazy vampire from letmein a
memory from his past
hibbleton I would think a magician than
the most complicated one I've ever seen
can we fix him of course we can fix it I
really don't want to divulge much of the
plot of this movie I'll just say that
through various connections he makes
with these characters a huge dreamlike
adventure starts that reminds me of what
it's like to be a kid reminds me of the
amazing youthful bliss of being young of
finding something you like using your
imagination discovering something you
love and really delving into your dreams
and just being a kid again
Hugo is one of the best films of the
year I love this movie so much peace
secret is that I think it's the message
for my father why would my key fits into
your father's machine to finding his way
home this is a treacherous place do you
understand
Scorsese is a master filmmaker and this
is his first foray into family
entertainment and also 3d which is
lately been a big gimmick and sometimes
just used for money and extra gain not
here this is one of the best uses of 3d
I have ever seen
I implore you not to see this movie in
anything other than 3d for anyone who
loves movies for anyone who ever had a
childlike dream for anyone who's ever
used his imagination for anyone who has
any type of youthful just bliss inside
them just wanting to explode this is
your kind of movie we should get into
suckle that's how you know an adventure
you've tried to cook pasta so it's time
to try the entire term movie magic is
meant for movies like Hugo the young boy
in this film a sub utter field sure I
said that incorrectly he is very good
Chloe grace Moretz is also great Ben
Kingsley is fantastic the brief amount
of time the Jude Law was in the movie he
was very good as well
a stunning kind of revelation this movie
is Sasha Baron Cohen as this guard he is
hilarious but he's also very heartfelt
this Thanksgiving
Academy award-winning director Martin
Scorsese invites you on an incredible
journey
written well acted well directed well it
looks wonderful the 3d is fantastic it's
heartfelt it has a meaning it evokes a
dreamlike magical sense of youth it's
just a great film
I loved it it's one of the best phones
of the year for sure this movie just
reminded me why I go to movies it's one
of those movies that just makes you
remember ah yes this is why movies are
made I implore you
check out Hugo it's one of Martin
Scorsese's best films once upon a time I
met a boy named Hugo Cabret
you search to find a secret message I
need to know what this means and have a
message
this is way
all the way so comment below and stuck
when squared let me know what kind of
Martin Scorsese movies do you like
have you seen you go what do you think
of it let me know if you like this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck mine eyes